oh my watch is dead ah what time is it
it's 9 51 p.m I just had a long day of
Chess uh played two games today in this
video I'm gonna recap my second round
game this is a Reykjavik open if you
missed the first round recap a link
below you can see the recent video on my
channel I'll be having a whole playlist
of all my recaps the playlist below as
well but in this game I played on board
three one of the top seeds Grand Master
yomas Mustafa or Mustafa your mouse uh
strong GM and I prepared a little bit uh
last night and I actually woke up this
morning around 8 A.M and I thought the
round was at 11 A.M but it was actually
at 9am I was planning to spend a couple
hours in the morning preparing but then
I realized I had no time because the
round was at nine I was lucky to have
not missed around but I was also
fortunate that I looked at some lines
the previous day and we got something
that was pretty fresh in memory I opted
for E4 and went for a line that I've
actually never played before I played
Bishop to B5 before but I've never
played the following move in this
position and uh the move I played is the
fifth most popular move Bishop to A4 let
me hide everything to avoid spoilers
Bishop A4 it's kind of a newish trendy
move that became popular over recent
years and it's kind of a hard move to
explain but essentially black is
preparing A6 to chase the bishop and if
A6 is played then I'm pretty much
provoked to take on D7 so the point of
Bishop to A4 is A6 doesn't hit the
bishop and black plays A6 white can
respond with C4 preventing Pawn B5 and
then giving the bishop some room and
later going for D4 so there is some
logic to the move I know it breaks in
principle moving the same piece twice
and away from the center but this is
still prepped 906 was played castling
and here I said oh no my pawn and
um the pawn is I believe poisonous in
this position now I'll admit I didn't
really look at this line too deeply in
my preparation because I I knew that he
wasn't going to go for it but um the
idea here for white is to play rookie
one Knight F6 and then D4 and after
takes takes uh White has a lot of
compensation for the pawn there's some
pins in the position with e-file and the
diagonal and just to show something
funny if black plays G6
preparing the fiancado why you can just
take the Knight because this and this
are pinned to the king so of course that
didn't happen uh my Pawn was not taken
instead pani6 was played and then I play
Pawn C4 and again I say oh no my Pawn
now interestingly enough I saw one game
previously from my opponent uh he was
playing a grand master maze I think in
the world Rapid or Blitz and
um Mustafa actually took the pawn E4
against Maze and there's a cool line
that results from this position after
rookie one Knight F6 D4 takes takes and
uh Bishop E7 and this was his exact game
against Maze and this position white has
a really really cool move which I guess
if you want to try and find you can
pause the video or you can just pull up
Gotham chess on Tick Tock and he'll
probably scream sacrifice
book takes E6 uh it's actually a really
cool bit of preparation because after
takes takes whites down a rook but
there's just a ton of compensation and I
looked at this uh this is one of the few
lines I looked at right before the game
and uh there's some weird engine draw
like after Queen A5 pretty sure the the
top line is C5 B5 Bishop takes B5 Queen
takes there's a triple fork and then
after King F7 white has nothing better
than just to repeat and this would be a
funny draw and I was ready to go into
this uh both sides have to walk a very
thin line to get to this position but we
did not draw the game within 15 moves
and I did not sacrifice a rook I didn't
even end up sacrificing the pawn because
he did not take on e4 instead he played
Bishop E7 and then uh we got a more
normal type position after Knight C3
Castle D4 takes takes I get this murati
bind setup now this is a slightly
stranger Mozzy bind because usually the
bishop is on E2 rather than A4 but at
the same time White's controlling a nice
man space and I was still within my prep
uh A6 Queen E2 Queen C7 and I'm pretty
sure I had this position on my computer
at some point uh maybe a day before the
game I was familiar with just some
general plans in the position I started
here with King H1 idea I want to play F4
and not have to worry about a long
diagonal I should also note that there's
cases where I want to play Bishop to E3
but this is met with knights
to E5 hitting the pawn and also
preparing Knight G4
so when I play King H1
one nice benefit is that when I play F4
and Bishop F3 uh if Knight G4 ever
happens the bishop can Retreat to G1 so
it's an extra bonus of the king being
here so from here my opponent played
Knight to E5 hitting a pawn I played
Bishop to B3 really the only logical way
to defend the pawn I didn't want to play
B3 and
um actually I think B3 is a plunder due
to B5 and like Bishops trapped and if
takes my knight hangs so Bishop B3 looks
a little bit ugly but uh it's called
four in this position he plays Knight to
C6 I defend and then Knight to A5 and
then I go for F4 and I was feeling
pretty good here like I'm completed with
development black still has to
activate the queen side pieces and it
seemed like very quickly I'll have some
potential to attack on the king side or
just in the center very common idea is
Pawn E5
and after rookie 8 Bishop F2 B6 I get in
the movie E5 and just expand hitting the
Knight Knight retreated to D7 and then I
bring the bishop to G3 so creating some
extra Vision against the queen and after
Bishop to B7 this is a moment where I
had a move in mind and rather than
calculating and taking a lot of time I I
played my next move pretty quickly
because it's just such an intuitive move
I went ahead and played Pawn F5 and the
reason why this was just very intuitive
is because it's making three different
pieces happier in the position
essentially I'm opening up lines for my
Bishop my rook and potentially the other
Bishop there's cases where this bishop
comes to life maybe in the not so
distant future there's C5 and I can
Target the king along this diagonal so
F5 I thought was just a really nice way
to apply a ton of pressure and
um actually I did spend about seven
minutes to play this move but it felt
like uh a quick think given that there's
a lot of complications that can arise
with all these different captures of
course I'm also um pressuring E6 given
that there's two attackers now and after
I played this move uh just one funny
tidbit as my opponent was thinking none
other than vastly evanchuk walked by and
he stopped and just gazed at this
position and it felt so good to have a
legend uh watching over and maybe
admiring this move I don't know what was
going through his mind maybe he he was
thinking this was just a joke for whites
but in the moment I was feeling good and
my opponent took some time and it took
on E5 now it looks like this hits the
knights but the pawn is pinned so I
don't actually have to move the knights
instead I take on East 6 and after Pawn
takes E6 I ended up taking a pretty long
think here because the move I initially
wanted to play was Knight takes E6
hitting the queen and this looks really
good for white at first glance but I
wasn't sure how to meet Queen C6 here
because this not only applies pressure
to the g-pawn but also puts my knight in
an awkward spot and my knight is just
about trapped in this position like if I
defend it I just got mated and if I play
Pawn C5 there's Knight takes B3 and
queen E6 I spent a long time trying to
calculate this line Knight G7 King G7
and then what was I looking at Bishop A4
ideas later of Queen G4 but then there's
Queen E6
and I spent a long time like trying to
calculate the forcing lines but I
couldn't arrive at like a definite
conclusion
so rather than trying to force matters I
decided not to take the pawn on E6 but
rather played Bishop to C2
improving the bishop and trying to
Target H7 Pawn now my opponent played
Bishop F6 I play Queen H5 just trying to
bring as many pieces towards the king
side as possible he defends with Knight
f8 and I still leave my nylon D4 and
improve my other knights with Knight E4
and in this moment I was thinking about
a Kasparov quotes he had like a really
nice quote that I I don't remember the
exact wording but he said something like
if you have more attackers then the
opponent has Defenders then it's
generally just a winning attack like
mathematically uh one two three four
five six attackers should overpower
fewer Defenders so uh I felt inspired by
Kasparov in in this position just trying
to uh attack with as many things as
possible and here of course I'm
threatening to take on F6 so black still
needs to defend he played Queen E7 and
then I finally moved my knight to F3 so
here I'm still down the pawn but this
Pawn is really weak and I thought it's
very likely that I'll be able to take it
soon and then he takes on C4 and um I
will say that I've analyzed the game
briefly with the engine and this is
actually a really key moment because
after he took on C4 I mean he spent
about a minute on this move
um I saw that he was threatening Knight
E3 and I very quickly played
rookie one you can see based on the
timestamp I spent about 30 seconds
because there is a 30 second increment
now rookie one looks very normal it's
improving my last piece uh preventing
Knight E3 but it turns out that white
has a winning tactic here
and both of us just completely missed it
and it was actually very very simple so
if you want to pause the video it's
white to move it's essentially a two
move combination to win a piece and what
I should have done was just pause for a
moment and acknowledge this Knight is
just undefended and I should look for
the forcing moves look for checks and
captures turns out the winning move is a
check and a capture Knight takes F6 and
actually for the next few moves I I
didn't want to play this because after
Pawn takes the queen defends and um I
thought this structure is very solid but
in this position white has Queen G4 and
I'm just winning a knight
um so for this reason if black can't
take with Pawn the queen has to take
this isn't much better for black this is
probably even worse because then Knight
G5 and simple attack on the queen attack
on H7 White's completely winning here
um so it was a little bit disappointing
that I missed such a simple combination
um especially because it was just an
easy to consider move it just required
the board vision
but uh I played rookie one I was still
feeling good he plays Rook C8 I played
Bishop to B1 I was sensing some issues
like black might be threatening Knight
D2 or even Knight E3 to try and trade
off my Bishop
um so I wanted to preserve it right
after I played Bishop E1 I regretted not
even considering Rook F2 maybe this is a
better option but um game went on he
plays Rook d8 then I play Rook F2 and
then there's some trade on e4 he plays
Knight D6 Bishop to C2 and then Queen F7
so I'm still down the pawn but still
have some initiative on the king side
and in this moment it looks like I can
trade queens and win the pawn however
this would be a big mistake if I take on
F7 takes there are three attackers only
two Defenders but if we calculate until
the end of the line takes takes takes
takes take six black to move and win
Rook takes C2 and oh no I'm getting made
in llama back rank so
um I I was aware of my back ring
problems and generally when you're the
one attacking that you want to keep
Queens on the board so I cut my queen uh
on the board played Queen G4 and then he
plays Rook C4 which I did not see coming
but uh turns out this wasn't such an
annoying move because I just go back to
H3 and The Rook is actually a Target now
ready to bring the bishop back to this
diagonal and try and shish kebab all of
the back pieces so he plays Knight to F5
perhaps trying to induce some more
traits but then I grabbed the pawn on E5
and uh now I'm only down one Pawn I was
down two pawns for uh for many moves but
um
I was feeling good because if Bishop
takes Bishop I take and Fork so black is
under serious serious pressure he plays
Knight G6 I play Bishop B3 hitting the
Rook Rook C6 and then Rook E2 so just
building a pressure against this weak E6
points and I'm essentially using pieces
from all directions to targets uh one of
the weakest points in Black's position
he takes on E5 and then I played a
really nice move which took me a little
moment to consider I went ahead and
played Rook takes E5 not taking with a
knight which is generally more natural
but allowing black to take the Rook
because if he does I'm not only winning
back the exchange but in the end let's
say queen C7 I would take take and then
take on F5 and just winning a piece
there's a pin on the diagonal
so black is under serious serious
pressure here then he plays on the four
and as we can see we're both very low on
time
um he played this move with 12 seconds
left I was also falling pretty low on
time and here I saw my queen was
attacked I saw that Knight T3 is an idea
and I didn't really take much time to
play the move Queen to G4
um but I really should have slowed down
and again considered
just uh the forcing moves of forcing
captures in the position because I
missed just another very simple winning
tactical opportunity if you want to try
and find it pause the video but the
simple move is Queen takes F5
oh no my queen and if he takes it
I'm mating on E8 and this is what I
missed like I was considering this I
just missed some amazing idea after it
takes takes this is Checkmate because
the queen is pinned to the king and this
would have been a really nice way to
finish things off
um turns out also Rook takes off five is
winning
um because it forces trades and wins
material but I miss both both of those
moves I still thought Queen G4 was
winning because I'm threatening to take
the Knight I'm also threatening to take
on F5 and I calculated that if Knight to
D3 then I just take on E6 and then
there's massive issues for black with
the bishop piercing through the position
but he managed to find a really nice
resource to defend here Knight to D4 uh
essentially covering both nights moving
this Knight away from danger defending
the Knight on F4 and also covering the
pawn and also attacking my Bishop so
this is just such a multi-purpose move I
was trying to figure out if I still have
a win here I went ahead and took on D4
after takes played G3 and I still
thought the position is really close to
winning given that there's this pin uh
against the the fourth Rank and and if
Knight E2 attempting to defend I just
take it and I win a piece so it looks
like White's on the verge of winning
material but he comes up with another
really nice resourceful counter-attack
Pawn H5 and my queen can't really stay
pinning because of Queen H4 then Knight
E2 becomes possible and it's this weird
geometry where the Knight defends her
Rook which hits the queen also covers
Queen dhek and he's running Checkmate in
one so unfortunately I had to retreat
with the queen and then he plays Knight
D5 and I believe this was move 39 yeah
this is move next move is move 39 so I
should note that on move 40 we both get
an additional half hour we'll see the
time stamps change very soon so after
Queen E2 he plays Knight C7 and then I
played Rook takes H5 and he plays Queen
G6 and this point we both have half hour
extra I know the clocks didn't updates
but um yeah the position has really
transformed over the last several moves
and somehow I did not manage to get any
sort of winning position
um and black is almost completely
Consolidated but in the moment I still
felt like I was better here because of
the pressure against E6 and I still
thought I was playing for a win I played
Rook to E5 now I have four attackers
against the pawn
he played Queen H6 and here I was
thinking about taking the pawn because I
do have four attackers he only has three
Defenders
but if I take the pawn here
it's not so simple because he can take
takes takes takes
and after takes takes I think this is
just a draw Rook D1 King G2 he wins the
pawn in the end actually everything just
simplifies and I would have to be
careful maybe play A4 and this should be
a draw Rook before I have A5 so that
didn't happen I didn't want to simplify
everything and just settle on a draw I
wanted to push for a win so I opted for
Queen to F3 and he played the move Rook
to C1 and here I really wanted to play
the move Rook takes E6 which at first
looks really close to winning because
I'm hitting the queen and opening the
diagonal and if he takes I take back
with check and this is really good for
whites
and another calculation is if he takes
E6 I would take and if King moves over
then white has some mating Nets and I'm
pretty sure this is winning eventually
Bishop Bishop F5 and then Queen
this should be winning I think here here
here
um here yeah eventually like I take on
G6 and then take and I have two extra
pawns so I was dreaming of making this
work but after Rook E6 he can take and
after Bishop takes he can take with
Queen because my Rook is pinned on the
the first Rank and after I take here I'm
up a pawn it still looks like white has
decent winning chances but then there's
Rook D2 and I spent a long time trying
to calculate these lines and I just
didn't see how white can play for a win
here because the pawns on the queen side
are very weak and there's not a great
way to exploit a black king my king is
actually a bit Airy on each one
so after a bit of a think
I decided to play the move Pawn each
four in this position
simply trying to expand on the king side
maybe someday set up rook to G5
um but it turns out H4 is a really bad
tactical blender and so far this game
it's been me missing tactical
opportunities for myself but here I
missed a very strong tactic for my
opponents and my opponent found it and I
I didn't even see it coming until he
played the move uh if you want to pause
the video you can try and find the
tactic for black move is Rook takes H4
taking advantage of the fact that if I
take
he can take and hit my Rook on E1
and this is not good for white actually
maybe even better is to start with Rook
takes E1 and then take and it would lead
to a position where white is down two
pawns and yeah black has very very good
chances to convert
so uh yeah once I saw Rook H4 on the
board I just had that sinking feeling in
my stomach that things have gone
terribly wrong but I realize the games
is still not over because I can play on
with King G1 and it's not immediately
crushing her back because each one is
under control my rook's defended but
then he played a really nice move here
Queen D2 leaving his Rook on pre and
hitting my Rook on E1 and what this does
is essentially simplifies matters it
provokes me to trade Rooks and then
trade Queens if I play Queen F1 there's
this tactic Rook H1 so I didn't want to
blunder my queen but after the queen
trade
black is up a clean pawn and he still
has initiative two Rook attacking the
bishop on D1 also preparing Rook to D2
and after Bishop to B3
um he played just a really classy move
here and I think his next move shows his
strength as a GM that he was able to
evaluate the resulting end game he
played Rook D2 if I wear black I would
be very hesitant to allow simplification
Bishop takes E6 I did play this move
after it takes takes takes takes this
looks like very close to a draw because
it's two on three and there's a lot of
cases where even if you're up a pawn in
a rook ending there there's good chances
for the side with less pawns to hold but
in this position he just understood that
black has a pretty clean winning path
and I'll just play through the next
several moves showing the winning
strategy for black I had to defend the
pawn and he prevents me from playing
Pawn A5 so I can't liquidate the queen
side
I was forced to wait and then he plays
G5 brought the pawn to G4 and now the
plan is simply to play Rook B4 walk the
king over defend the pawn and then
either win this Pawn or this pawn and
there's really not much I can do there's
really no counter play because from the
Rooks on B4 it defends both pawns and my
king is completely cut off
so next several moves were just a lot of
sadness
I tried to play on and create some trick
but yeah the checks run out eventually
he hides his King on A6
and I had one final trick after King C3
takes King B3 rookie four I played the
move Rook F6 and here I said oh no my
Pawn because after he played this I
played King A4 he can't meet me because
the pawns pinned and when he took my
Pawn
I took on B6 and he took back
and it's stalemate
and then I woke up from all my Daydreams
and realized that this didn't happen he
didn't play rookie three he first plays
Pawn A4 and then he wins a Pawn on G3
very cleanly so there's no stalemate
trick and I resigned in this position it
was a really painful game uh I think in
total the game lasted about five hours
and uh yeah I had multiple winning
chances and if if I had won this game it
would have been one of my best upsets
ever uh at least one of the highest
rated players I've ever defeated but um
I don't know exactly the reason for just
missing the simple tactics it may have
been not identifying the key moments it
may have been some issues with time
management slowing down
I woke up this morning at like 4 a.m so
I'm still a little bit jet lagged and I
don't like to make excuses but I think
it's really really important when you
have a game like this with just so many
missed opportunities and blunders you
can't really think that I'm stupid and
uh I'm just a bozo for missing so so
many moves but it's so important to
reflect and actually identify what
caused these mistakes to happen
and try and resolve them for for future
games and future tournaments I might
have to just do more tactical training
might have to work on my physical
stamina and sleep and just alertness of
the board maybe I should be prepared
with more tea but uh yeah it was a
painful game but some valuable lessons
uh I'm I'm upset but at the same time I
was happy to get a good fight and also
happy to get great opening preparation
and be in a spot to take down a strong
GM
so what to do I kind of felt like I
needed a therapy puppy after this game
but
um yeah I'm gonna wrap it up here
because it's getting really late and I
still have to recap my round three game
which I played just a couple hours after
this game finished so stay tuned for the
round three recap really appreciate you
watching until the very end don't forget
to subscribe and I'll see you in the
next one